journalism is under attack
like never before well no personal
creature gas fire you have to have the
fact
beautiful but tragic because people are
doubting everything
you're the only way of telling their
story how would you describe this
outbreak something like an apocalypse
you're going to be
really tired you're going to be really
scared it's too dangerous
anyone who says they're not scared is
life anything can happen
did you get here i sometimes wonder how
have we managed to get out of this be
killed
we do genuinely believe in what we do
he's clearly martin's press
to show the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover
on injustice this is the result of
ethnic cleansing i don't think any
journalist wants anything more than that
i'm alex crawford i'm stuart ramsey and
this is hot spots
[Music]
it's the most hit city in the most hit
province coming up on hot spots
we returned to italy to the town that
was the epicenter
of the coronavirus outbreak this is
still our covered
area they took it really seriously and
they still are
we witnessed the devastation caused by a
massive explosion in beirut
every single building is affected they
were
terrified
this killer pandemic is virtually out of
control
it is absolutely full they were at a
point where they were doing their
absolute best and their best was not
good enough
the families can't see them everyone
here dies alone
we wanted to go back and see how things
have changed
a place that has had so much impact on
you personally and also globally
it's nice to see it coming back to
normal the worst place with the worst
outbreak is actually recovering so much
better
[Music]
bergamo at one stage was the absolute
epicenter of
the worst outbreak in the world
place was basically a ghost town
this kind of fairy tale place from what
it looked like was the center of the
coronavirus epidemic at that time in the
world and
that was hard to believe
it was dead silent you know
everyone says it it's like the movie
28 days later that is exactly what it
felt like
not seeing any life at all just you know
that's what
helped you understand that it really was
happening
it was a town and a region that was
genuinely scared
it's the most hit city in the most hit
province in the most hit country in
europe
everyone knew somebody who was either
ill or died
it's like the plague coveted started to
spread around the world but up until
that point
we hadn't actually seen it in such
dramatic fashion
i wasn't part of the team on that trip
but watching stuart's reports from italy
at the time
really drove it home
[Music]
we were probably the first to see it
first to broadcast it
and sure enough even though people had
doubted what we were saying
that is exactly what happened
how are you we had hoped that we might
be able to see what happens when
coronavirus overwhelmed society
overwhelms medical facilities but you
know up until that point we hadn't had
much luck getting any access
is it possible for us to get into the
hospital here do you think dave we have
all of the equipment
but a chance meeting with the mayor of
bergamo really opened up the door for us
to go
and visit the papa giovanni hospital in
bergamo
you had no idea what to really expect
we had prepared for the possibility that
we'd be in a very
highly infectious environment
none of us expected to see what we saw
there were a lot of ill people
it's terrible this is not what we
expected
people have keep describing this as like
flu it's worse than that
no it's totally another thing
it's a very severe animal roberto
constantino is the emergency admissions
director in the outbreak it was his
department that is absolute front line
and was overwhelmed
instantly even in the midst of it he
took time to explain things to us
because he wanted to get that message
out this was that dangerous
something like an apocalypse
dr costantini was basically sending out
a warning to the rest of the world that
if you don't want your hospital to look
like this
lock down now don't get to the point
where you think oh no it won't happen to
us because it will
and he was absolutely right people have
only just arrived here
and they're in terrible shape this
killer pandemic
is virtually out of control
ultimately he let us into the emergency
ward
because i think he understood that it
was now bigger even than his hospital
and that they were at a point where they
were doing their absolute best and their
best was not good enough
this is what it looks like when the
virus overwhelms and here in lombardy
it's overwhelming
these patients are critically ill in all
probability
they won't make it
what we saw was what everyone was about
to see and i remember in the evenings
ringing home and saying
you've got to listen to what i'm saying
you've got to follow the rules
i could never have imagined the effect
it was going to have because there
hadn't been a story like this before
there hadn't been a pandemic in over 100
years
[Music]
we wanted to go back and see what it was
like now how things had changed
going back to exactly the same places
trying to meet exactly the same people
bergamo holds an incredibly special
place in my heart i feel
connected to it in a way that i've
actually never felt connected to
a story in a way that
italy had sent the message to the world
of what was going to happen to them
perhaps there was another message to be
sent about what it's like
so many months later on when we returned
to bergamo
three months later it was sunny and warm
i was expecting a place to be a virtual
ghost town
but what i discovered was a town that
was really coming back to life
suddenly there were people on the
streets we'd only ever seen it empty
and it was nice but it was odd i mean
really really
odd feeling because i wasn't here
when you first came it's quite difficult
for me to
to picture it if i had if i hadn't seen
the piece before
it's nice to see it coming back to
normal everybody was wearing a mask and
when i say everybody i actually do mean
everybody
it would be very rare to see somebody
without a mask on in bergamo
i think it's because they follow the
lockdown rules and they still do there
was a real sense of optimism
and community spirit you could see that
the people in the town were really happy
to be out and about
the ongoing point of why the worst place
with the worst outbreak is actually
recovering so much better
because they took it really seriously
they were shocked into taking it
seriously
but they did and they still are
well any of us will any nation will
italy ever be
quite the same again do you think things
have changed forever nobody of us
will be the same georgio gory the mayor
very charismatic and he was the key to
everything really
his message was absolutely clear it was
like you have to lock
down do not waste another minute
maybe it affects people on a small level
as well maybe when we left
after on the first trip we said we'll
come back and
he said i absolutely insist you come and
see me if you come back and i said
listen
we give you our word
and so we met up with him late one
evening once he'd done his day's work
and he was he was so happy to see stuart
so happy to see the team again
he did not expect the attention
that his warning got and he said the
effect here was remarkable because
within a week 22 million euros have been
pledged to the bergamot hospital
the main point that the mayor made to us
when we saw him again
was that the virus is here to stay we
all hope
to wake up a day and have a good news
concerning the the backs but until that
day
i think that we will live in
in this
strange condition so here we are we're
back at uh papa giovanni hospital
um the placer uh when we first visited
we didn't know what to expect and uh
now we're coming back to see things are
meant to have changed significantly now
um because it was at one point the worst
hit hospital
anywhere don't touch honestly
many people told us nobody knew what was
going on in their own hospitals in
bergman
the first time they'd seen what's going
on in their own hospitals was
when we reported it yeah so this is this
is uh this is it
this is just full yeah
the hospitals we revisited in lombardy
the wards had been completely full when
we were there
now completely empty
ordinary medicine was taking place again
i thought to myself
it doesn't even look like the same
hospital how are you
roberto concertini he's still there in
his admissions room
he looked so much more relaxed uh he he
looked like
a man with the weight of the world of
his shoulders this is still our
covered area seeing them again when it
had sort of
calmed down to a degree they didn't
realize
what they were doing was abnormal in its
own right either
they've said to us and then realized
that this was absolute
apocalypse we just had no time to think
sometimes we think back on what we saw
yeah
and we asked ourselves was it real yeah
we actually do that
yeah yeah yeah it's very surreal we
realized now the impact that the story
had had
he was the one to explain to me that
actually
it still makes people extremely ill and
it's
much worse than just a respiratory
illness it
affects your whole body it is a systemic
illness and also now we see
a significant proportion of the
population
with chronic damage from from the virus
it was clear that they were traumatized
by what they went through
we spoke to doctors in a number of
hospitals in the area and they all
shared the same feeling
what is worse is not only that more
often than not they can't save their
patients
it's that they also know that they are
alone
the families can't see them now
everyone here dies alone
i think they were only now three
four five months later realizing
how that trauma has actually affected
them personally
the trauma you you feel for is very
similar to a post-traumatic stress
that you you can imagine to be in a
battlefield
or something like that
the next batch of the lost waiting for
cremation are laid out in the hospital
chapel before collection
their families couldn't say goodbye
they're all in quarantine
the first time we went to bergamo we
couldn't get into the cemetery
what was going on at the time was far
too sensitive and emotional and so we
kept a discreet and respectful distance
outside and did some filming
bergamo's magnificent cemetery is
receiving a new body
every single hour time is strictly
allotted for the funerals of loved ones
to take place
and there's a huge backlog they break
the curfew
to pay their last respects
when we went back this time around it's
very different because it's now
completely open
we walked in and straight up and to our
right we saw all the freshly dug
graves cemeteries are always a moving
place especially a magnificent one like
this
but all of those knew dead these were
people who
were often quite young people who
actually may have had illnesses but
weren't due
to dying coronavirus claimed their lives
we looked at some of them and you know
we could see actually that the age range
was actually quite vast you know this
whole idea that it only affected the
elderly
we saw some people buried there who were
in their 20s
it was really sad to see those young
lives cut
short
when we were decided that we were going
to come back to this trip we decided we
were going to speak to everyone
that we had met if we could serena and
michaela were
one of the few people we met in the
streets of the old
city the vast majority of those dying
here
are in the high risk elderly group
serena and michael
are both 73
they came out to get some sun for the
first time in days
they never leave each other and they
meet no one and they're still scared
they stayed on our minds you know all
throughout
we were trying to find serena and
mckellen who
were a couple in their 70s who we met in
bergamo
at the height of the lockdown they were
the only couple the only people
we couldn't get hold of we've not been
able to contact them we've
pretty much found everyone else we've
met so well we're sort of a bit worried
that they're
they're okay the team were really keen
to
track them down they had been talking
about an awful lot
and so we embarked on this uh journey
to do a bit of detective work and and
try and track them down
it's like where are we going to start
well ultimately you go back to the most
classic
journalism that you'll ever do which is
literally knock on
doors so this is who we're looking for
we've got it's black and white we've got
colour as well of course
but this is the street just here
and each shop you went to they just
didn't know them and didn't recognize it
and so we sort of thought about well
maybe this is getting nowhere we just
started yeah
and it felt like sort of good
old-fashioned gumshoe journalism to be
honest
we can try oh ah as we
left one shop the shop owner a lady came
out and said listen there's a
there's a guy in the delicatessen
a little whale and if anyone
knows anyone it's going to be him
we got our pictures out and he got his
glasses on and he
started looking at photos and it was
like i don't recognize him because of
the masks
and then he said hang on i know them
it's uh serena and michael
and they live around the corner so then
we knew he they were fine which was
really great
that sounds great um
it's fantastic news oh my goodness me ah
yeah it was amazing somebody rang the
bell and spoke to them
it's sky news it was i had sky news he
couldn't believe it and we said we're
here he said please please come in
everyone saw about the oh really
great he came down and he said yeah
immediately you can come and
come in and come in we went in this
really beautiful house
they were so excited to see us they
insisted on us all drinking champagne
and i know stewart in particular felt
sort of really quite moved by the moment
because actually he was worried that
they actually didn't make it i mean
really you can explain
we really wanted to come and say hello
and see how you are
and and ask your thoughts about
everything that happened and they gave
us an amazing interview telling us what
it had been like over those months
how they had seen these obituaries how
they knew people that had died
and it had really scared them but they
determined to stay
inside their house as long as possible
and they had done
that's pretty that's pretty special
isn't it pretty amazing
for us as a story going back and
actually finding safe and sound
and happy was just fantastic
in the days after our story came out
stewart was getting a lot of emails from
viewers i still remember stuart coming
to me and said i've gotten an email from
a woman named beryl
and basically she was telling me off
it's like you know you you keep
your programs keeps running and it's
depressing me and he said yeah i know i
can't reply to everyone but i do feel
like i want to
reply to beryl because she's
basically a representative of so many
thousands if not tens of thousands of
elderly people who find themselves alone
and isolated and lonely
and we sort of became friends so like
pen pals really
and she started critiquing all my work
everything i did
and then we said i promised that one day
if we ever came back to birth and we'd
take her out for lunch
so when we went back to italy i said to
you you know you've got to take beryl
out for lunch he said i know i have to
take beryl out for lunch and i'm really
looking forward to it
what did you think when it first struck
personally i thought they're exaggerated
i was wrong they weren't exaggerating
and in fact all the lockdowns were
absolutely necessary
stuart and dominique had been reading
beryl's emails for months
and uh they were really keen to catch up
with her it was it was great she was
lovely
this is my this is my favorite place i
can see my computer from there and see
where
when
any emails come in it was just fantastic
to actually
finally meet this person who had
actually messaged me to tell me off
in the first place and she's really
fierce he's been a great grandfather
and he's on the team yes so are we
officially
and so what what is the lady to what is
your title then uh
i would be a bad on this very nice
lovely
i'm not i'm just an housewife it was
great you know it was exactly what we
thought you know here's a british woman
who's lived in italy pretty much all her
adult life
and was married to an italian and found
herself alone now
experiencing this this thing that all of
us have experienced for the first time
in life a global pandemic a global
lockdown
so we go you've got everything all right
and you've got your keys everything you
need
yes all of us cared about beryl
um with her daily updates telling us off
for the latest story with the
i think what was special about forming
in connection with beryl
she did represent so many people out
there
who were experiencing the lockdown by
themselves and who needed a friend who
needed something on the outside to
remind them that
life goes on and take barrel for lunch
yes barrel for lunch
quite a character baroness beryl no less
it wasn't work this was actually a
pleasure we just we went out and had a
fantastic lunch
i can't remember working on a story that
actually had such a positive impact
not just in the location itself further
afield as well
it's pretty much accepted that lockdown
happened in the uk three days after
our report went out never in a million
years did we expect that to happen
knowing what we know now i see how
that reporting in a way was prophetic it
was prophetic about what was to come
not just in the uk but in countries
around the world
the virus that attacked blondie was one
of the nastiest
forms of the virus it killed really
proportionately higher than it has in
other parts of the world
and yet they've dealt with it better
than others they have been
aggressive in trying to deal with this
disease and people
have been supportive of those aggressive
tactics and that is i think the
driving force of the success
they do not want a second wave
it was pretty clear that they had a
fairly dim view
of the uk and um when you speak to any
man or woman
in the street you'd explain where you
were from and they'd just
you know slap their head they thought we
were a bit of a joke actually
we all understand the virus a bit better
us as the public we understand what we
need to do now
what we what we need to do to try and
control it and to stop it spreading
you actually have to be a bit more
responsible about how you live and
perhaps
responsible for how you treat other
people so that you
you might be okay but you cut the days
of you just saying i'm fine
and i don't care what happens to you i
think those days are gone
but i hope
[Music]
you felt like it might have been a bomb
jesus christ shocking
in its ferocity
every single building is affected
they experience this stuff on a far too
regular basis
can you say hamdulillah thank god they
were terrified
weirdly i was on the phone to zayn when
the
the explosion happened i was in
istanbul and he was in beirut we were
talking about what was happening in
lebanon i was just giving her a brief
and catching up on things
there was suddenly this almighty noise
the phone wasn't cut off but there was
just this
complete noise it just filled everything
and i was thinking what on earth's that
instinctively i just hit the ground in a
split second
never probably experienced or heard
something so loud in my life
bits of glass sort of come over me parts
of the
ceiling collapse we're talking about
split seconds milliseconds here so it
was
very difficult to kind of totally
comprehend at that time what exactly had
just happened
i remember because i'm very polite
picking up the phone
he came back on and said oh my god
there's been an explosion
[Music]
jesus christ i have to be honest with
you it felt
straight away like it might have been a
bomb that had gone off
oh my god but you're still trying to
gather your own bearings and your senses
and just the whole flat and the building
and outside was covered in this kind of
orange dust
it just was absolutely everywhere i mean
the colour of the city
had changed my initial feeling was that
it's probably just a
another explosion caused by terrorists
everyone including myself immediately
assumed that it was
some sort of bomb
i know this sounds crazy but i kind of
feel like i need to start working the
authorities are saying that there
could be many many injured i saw across
downtown beirut many civilians
are covered in blood covered in shards
of glass clearly very seriously injured
it's no good me saying oh my god there's
been a massive explosion it's been crazy
it's terrible it's
madness it's chaos because actually i
also need to find that information
so far the authorities here in lebanon
are saying that what caused this
explosion
uh was seemingly an industrial accident
a fireworks
depot in the port of beirut had some
sort of explosion
and that's led to an almighty blast all
we had in those first few days
was this theory that it was ammonium
nitrate that had exploded
but no one had been allowed into the
site of the port
i need to get closer to the scene to try
and understand what's happened when it's
happened who's responsible what's going
on how many people are injured how many
people have been killed
it's one thing to react to something
that's happened it's another thing to be
part of that thing that's happened and
you're actually totally
blind to the reality of what's going on
you know you don't have any sense of
perspective
you're actually part of this kev and i
started packing
our bags and getting ready to go because
we didn't know what had happened
we just knew it was big
we're constantly seeing these videos
cctv cameras finding the moment of
impact
each one more harrowing than the next
the young lady taking her her wedding
photos
was no more than 10 or 15 meters away
from where skye's office is where i was
at the point of the blast
the actual footage was
shocking in its ferocity
the blast wave that just seemed to to
spread and rip through
almost kind of without stopping
endless wave of explosion across the
city
and across the country
[Music]
we headed straight to meet zayn who
hadn't slept at all
and as soon as we got out of the car he
said we've got no time to sleep we've
just got to get
straight down there so once we get out
of this tunnel on your left-hand side
the port and the neighborhood of jamaica
and then downtown's right in front of
you
everything was in a state of chaos
so this checkpoint has been around for
several months
of protests since last october
protesting the government
and against corruption and the economic
crisis in the country
we're all very anxious because we knew
we had to get a report together for the
morning news get down what are we doing
across the other side of these buildings
is the port and the scene of the
explosion
you ready i'd like to think there aren't
many things that
surprise or shock alex crawford after so
many years in journalism
every single building that you can see
is affected there isn't one that isn't
affected around here i really got
the sense that even she and kev were
taken aback by the level of destruction
and i was i couldn't believe what i was
seeing
[Music]
when we turned up it was
it it looked like a war zone that was
the
only thing you could liken it to every
building was
smashed to bits everywhere
you go every street has been affected
kev just constantly filming at every
angle i mean he couldn't stop
and alex was obviously trying to speak
to people who would just experience one
of the biggest explosions in modern
history
just hours earlier
wow oh my goodness this is in a terrible
state
i lose everything
look his father was sleeping here and he
obviously got
terribly injured bloodstains on the door
is he all right now my father's hospital
i'm so sorry
what a terrible thing to happen to you
i think one of the key things when you
arrive on a scene of
any disaster is the earlier
you get there the better chance there is
of getting
really accurate spontaneous
eyewitness accounts there is no real
future anymore in lebanon
if there is a boat now we will take the
boat and leave lebanon
follow us
morning good morning i'm so sorry to see
you like this are you all right
somehow i'm not very wrong all right
still i wanted to go to the hospital
i don't think you can be a good
journalist if you didn't also feel
some of what these people are going
through because you have to be
able to empathize why have you come here
i don't have house my house is up in the
third floor
and our shuttle is here all the doors
are open
and no house broken where we
they had no idea where they were going
to sleep
that night they hadn't slept all night
since the explosion
and they were terrified about what was
coming next how are you going to cope
where are you going to stay
i always feel a bit uneasy just poking
the camera into people's faces at their
lowest point
but we're there to witness and document
that
it's difficult it's not pleasant really
from the morning that alex and kevin had
arrived
i honestly felt that i was on the verge
of breaking down
at every conversation that alex would
hold with
residents
this is not a country not a country
i was bleeding from half past six
till half past and no hospital
accepting all the people are on the
street
bleeding you see my heart my clothing
there was anger but there was also
almost a resignation that
this is what they're used to now just
untold misery that's
inflicted on them and they experience
this stuff on a far too regular basis
there's a kind of cliche about the
lebanese being incredibly resilient
and i think actually sometimes it's been
self-perpetuating in lebanon that people
almost use this as a badge of honor
this is the first time that i felt
across the board people
had had enough they were totally broken
zayn was very much making light of his
experience which
he said to us that plenty of people had
died and
many thousands of people were still
suffering
oh that is quite a blast
this is where i was talking to you alex
crawford he was
resistant to do the show around on
camera
he was uncomfortable this used to be the
office
and this side of the i think all of the
apartments were much more
badly affected from this side this is
our colleague who
experienced it and we wanted him to tell
us
what was it like and what about lebanon
do you think because you've covered this
area
you've lived in this country i mean you
couldn't write it
that in the midst of the worst economic
crisis this country has ever
gone through when so many people are so
desperate
and a health crisis on top that you'd
have this kind of
disaster it's really upsetting
but as we say if you say hamdulillah
thank god it could be worse
and certainly for for me it could have
been a lot worse
the hospitals were utterly overwhelmed
you said
people screaming kids screaming body
parts
i saw a hand i saw two legs
he was standing there like this symbol
of defiance and resistance in the
lobby of the hospital this country is
hopeless
it is hopeless there was very high
number of people who were dying who they
couldn't save
some of the most moving reports were the
reports of injured children
the doctor was keen to show us
the youngest victim that they'd had
and she was in an incubator in intensive
care
and she had this huge bandage on her
head we're still
checking the ct scan of the brain and to
see how extensively is
bleeding that's tragic
that is tragic yeah she was four days
old
a little baby called sophie she's got
lots of lacerations
to her head that was the big worry
whether she'd been affected
neurologically or not
overwhelmingly you know you've got this
feeling of helplessness you know this
poor little
bundle in this you know incubator is
days old and
just have to go through you know this
explosion and the doctors
weren't sure whether or not they would
be able to operate
seeing as a tiny small
newborn baby so badly hurt
we were coming out of the children's
intensive care and i saw
two young people sitting outside
our newborn baby she's like four days
old
in the intensive care i think i think
we've just seen her
[Music]
i was breastfeeding my baby and the
explosion
explored everything in the house
look at me i tried to protect her
but i couldn't do more than this
they wanted to tell us everything about
what what had happened what's your first
baby
how are you coping we're doing
our best we
it was horrific so so difficult to hear
someone's
testimony like that and it did make me
think
just how many other mothers are in this
situation
and how many mothers are now and fathers
are grieving this morning
today because of what what's happened
because they've been through so many
terrorist atrocities
because they were also in the middle of
a massive
economic meltdown as well as
a coronavirus pandemic this explosion
came at a time when
the country the city was already on its
knees
very soon after the explosion it emerged
that there had been 2 750
tons of one of the most combustible
chemicals
sitting in hangar 12 for about
six years look how this huge
warehouse if we cross now kev um
including the goods inside have been
blown away
it's difficult to comprehend ammonium
nitrate
stored in the state of total disrepair
and disregard
in a hangar in the port i mean it was
total devastation
we had gone on the off chance to try and
talk to the
health minister and he said well we're
going to a field hospital
one of the countries that offered
support was russia
we noticed the search and rescue team
has broken off on their own where is our
dog handler
how difficult do you think it will be to
find survivors now
this is very important
because time is left
there's always hope kind of looked at
each other and said well
you know maybe we should follow them
yeah
where's the path let's get it going as
we approached the
port the guards at the entrance thought
we were part of the delegation
just keep going so they just kind of
waved us through
and there we are we're literally inside
the port which was
utterly surreal and it's the first time
anyone
had seen what the inside of that port
looked like
look at that look what it's done to
these buildings
and we found ourselves with the very
first
foreign search and rescue team who are
also seeing it
for the first time
[Music]
i can't find the words to describe it
beyond surreal and beyond harrowing it
honestly looked like a movie set
this is the epicenter of the explosion
and the destruction is just enormous
suddenly you saw in front of you these
huge
towering grain silos we were so close
that couldn't get it all in
in the one shot it was just this
crumbling hulk
right next to us and a couple of times i
thought actually i'm not sure we should
be this close because
the whole thing could collapse they
immediately set their dogs on the area
to try and see if they could
sniff any signs of life
it was the first time that we had a
clear sight of what was happening inside
that port
zane basically said come on let's try
and get a live up as quickly as possible
the likelihood of us even getting in and
now doing a live report from the scene
of this
explosion was improbable kev was
desperately trying to get the thing to
work
we were in the middle of nowhere in a
sense because everything had been
destroyed around
us so it wasn't working and suddenly
kev turns around and says right i've got
a live signal we can do this
this is ground zero and the people in
blue that you can see
are members of the russian search and
rescue team
this was the first time that most people
were up so close and
right at the epicentre of the explosion
[Music]
the diggers are working here they really
don't expect to find
anyone there alive anymore and because
of the
level of destruction it very much is a
recovery
operation here at least
not only were they trying to find
survivors
they were also trying to find conclusive
evidence of what had happened
to people and at the beginning they just
kept on finding body parts
every family we spoke to who had loved
ones
either killed or missing at that time
their anger
was very clearly directed at the state
to many lebanese it seemed like a
massive catastrophe just waiting to
happen
and it had been sitting there waiting to
happen
for many many years
anger was building by the hour they
realized that
none of this needed to have happened
beirut just exploded in anger
i think in those protests people did not
go down to the streets
looking for culprits they were looking
for accountability
and now they wanted someone to face up
to that reality
and in their eyes it wasn't just the
government
that was responsible it was the
political establishment in lebanon
i think the explosion is when people hit
rock bottom it's when they realize that
actually
the likelihood of things getting better
any time soon
and the dangers that they were facing on
a daily level were so great that it
wasn't worth it
it wasn't worth the sacrifice but i
think that they feel totally hopeless
now
and that is heartbreaking
what really touched me about this uh
story i mean i've been to lebanon before
but it was really different working on a
disaster of this
magnitude with a colleague
who's actually lebanese
been at the seat of the tragedy but also
was
absolutely determined to carry on
working
it was surprising how well he was coping
i think it was just a determination to
tell the story and get it out there
lebanon as a country has got so many
scars now
and so many open wounds
i hope what happened that day may
eventually lead to
massive changes sadly many people
believe that it's going to take the
country
years and years to get over it
next time on hot spots the guy in charge
is like out of a tarantino movie
i'm in chihuahua in mexico where a story
about people smuggling
become something else entirely here was
a story
about one of our most precious natural
resources water
and my team are in houthi-controlled
north yemen
where they've now got coronavirus on top
of the horrors of civil war
80 of the population of yemen cannot
survive without
help until then you can find us on
twitter
at alex crawford sky and at ramsey sky
see you next time
[Music]
bring me
[Music]